there's a proliferation of outlets
obviously this is all painfully cliched
everyone is abundant everyone has become
a publisher everyone's become their own
editor and if you believe in democracy
and you believe in the First Amendment
you have to applaud that the First
Amendment's not just for people who pay
other people to gather news I do think
that there's a function for editors
there's a function for reporters who are
committed to a craft in which they do
the best they can at taking information
in as clinical away as possible not
necessarily a neutral and we all have
our biases we all have our prejudices we
all bring whatever we bring to the
process but we do make the best effort
possible at presenting information in a
clinical way and then people can do with
it what they want and that model is
under great economic stress I don't
think it's under great audience stress I
think people are adding to what they do
not subtracting if that makes sense and
so how we convince advertisers frankly
and people to pay subscription rates for
the news we gather is the great
challenge of the next 10 years and the
moment we figure it out twenty minutes
later it will change again but I'm
fairly bullish about it because i think
that the story will out it's always
about good stories it's always about as
horace one said both delighting and
instructing and that's been true for a
long long time and you know the advent
of prose didn't kill poetry so i think i
think we'll be all right we move faster
online you move faster it actually has
been liberating in print because we're
able to assume that people know just
about everything that happened by the
time they come to us so it enables us to
step back even farther to some extent
and really tell a story and as in as
inventive away as possible and so
it's increased the amount of overall
product we we put out there but it's
changed the weekly product in ways I
think are actually good for it inside
mr. Murdock I I think that actually kind
of flies in the face of what's happening
you can't have a proliferating media
universe where everyone can have their
own publication and then worry too much
about concentrated power is it a threat
certainly everything's a threat but my
sense and i work for a I guess a media
conglomerate I've never had a
conversation with our owners about we
should do this or not do that I think
that most conspiracy theories are wrong
for a reason and I'm I stay up at night
about how do we bring in a new
generation of people who would be
interested in the kind of analysis and
news we offer as opposed to worrying
about the top down I'm already at the
bottom up